So, today we're going to talk about
evaluation.
So, so far in this class, uh we've done
everything we need to train a language
model.
We define the architecture, the
optimizer, uh the main training loop. We
showed how to make
um
the training fast with kernels,
parallelism,
um and then we saw scaling laws.
Um we saw a little bit of how to make
uh inference fast as well.
So, only missing piece now is uh talking
about the data that you train on.
Um so, we're going to spend
next week talking about that.
Um and data is going to shape the model
behavior.
If you train on code, then presumably
your model is going to be good at code.
If you train only on DNA sequences, it
probably can't speak English. Um
but before we even get to data,
we need to talk about what behavior we
want from a model, and that's going to
be the topic of evaluation.
So, evaluation asks a very simple
question, given a model that we've
trained, how good is it?
So, what is good? So, evaluation might
seem
like a fairly mechanical process. You
define some prompts, you send these
prompts to your model, you get back some
responses, and then you compute the
accuracy. So, why do we have a whole
lecture on evaluation?
But actually, evaluation is a very deep
topic, and it's also very important
because evaluation is what shapes the
development of AI. Evaluation sets north
stars, and model developers, uh open,
closed, everyone looks at evaluation as
a sort of a um a measure of progress.
So, by thinking carefully about your
evaluation, you implicitly shape the
development of what your model is going
to be able to do.
So, what's harder value evaluation is
the following.
So, often you start with an abstract
construct of what do I want my model to
do?
Maybe I want my model to be
um
good at conversation or good at
reasoning.
Okay? So, those are abstract concepts.
And then, evaluation is really the
process of turning that into a concrete
metric powered by presumably some
concrete prompts or environments.
So, this is going to be uh the core
challenge and we'll see many examples of
how this process of abstract construct
to concrete um metric uh shows up.
So, let's go back to the question of
what makes a model good. Um just kind of
superficially,
uh maybe a model is good if it does well
on benchmarks. So, there's this um
website artificialanalysis, which has
become a bit of a standard for thinking
about um
um quote unquote intelligence of models.
Um so, if you go to
artificialanalysis.ai,
you can see a ranking of of different
models from GPT-5.5 all the way to down
Well, there's many more models um after
this point, but um
And so, this is um a measure
um includes a bunch of different data
sets um some of which we'll talk about.
Um or maybe a model is good if it does
well on benchmark and is also cheap to
run because cost should matter.
Um and this uh plot shows um both the
intelligence index from before, but
against how much uh money it costs to to
run a particular model based on, you
know, inference cost. Um and you can
see, of course, uh as you might expect,
that uh the two are correlated. The more
you pay to run, the higher the
intelligence index, but, you know, you
don't see it's not exactly aligned.
So,
but maybe a model is good if people just
prefer it.
Um, later we'll also go a little bit
more into depth. So, this is the take
that um, Arena AI, formerly known as
Chatbot Arena, takes.
Um, and you can form a a ranking based
on models based on whether people like
it or not.
Okay? Or maybe a model is good if people
simply choose to use it and therefore
pay for it. So, OpenRouter is this uh,
um,
uh, server that allows one to use
multiple uh, different models through a
um,
um, a central um, endpoint. And as a
result, they collect a lot of statistics
of what models people are using.
Um, and they publish uh, sta-
statistics, uh, which is really
interesting to look at the top models
um, that are are used through
OpenRouter. So, now this is not
representative of all model usage, but
it is gives you uh, a sense of what um,
people on OpenRouter are doing.
And so, this is kind of a more of
economic lens. I don't know what uh,
good is, but if people are paying for
it, it must be good. So,
um,
okay. So, you know,
none of those are really necessary the
correct answer. Um,
I don't know if there is a correct
answer, but um, just trying to get you
to think about different ways of
thinking about what good is.
So, let's start now um, by looking at
different ways, concrete ways of
evaluating language models.
And there's no better place to start
than going back to the the core idea of
a language model, which is that it's a
distribution P(x) over sequences of
tokens.
And through that lens, there's a very
natural way to evaluate of distribution,
which is a perplexity or, you know, like
likelihood uh, or log loss. Um, those
are all kind of related uh, concepts.
And it basically says, I have a test
data set, uh, D,
and I'm going to see how much, uh,
probability mass my language model
assigns to that D. And I normalize and
divide so that the numbers are, um, you
know, more interpretable. But that's
basically it. How much mass, uh, does my
probability language model, uh, assign
to a data set?
Okay, so this is fairly natural. In
fact, when we were doing training, we
minimized the perplexity on the training
set.
Okay, so the obvious thing to do is
measure the perplexity on the test set.
And this is what people traditionally
did in language modeling research for
many years. Throughout the uh, 2010s, if
you pick up a language modeling paper,
this is what they did. And back then,
uh, standard data sets included the Penn
Treebank, Wiki, uh, Text 103. There was
also this 1 billion word benchmark, um,
which was taken from,
um, you know, machine translation
sources,
um,
and and this is all in the classic
paradigm, which is in-distribution of
evaluation. You train on some train
split of that data set, and then you
evaluate on some test split of that data
set.
Um,
and
people actually made a lot of, uh,
progress, um, which was just measured in
perplexity reduction. So, for example,
there's this famous paper from 2016,
um,
which showed, uh, that you could apply,
you know, CNNs and LSTMs to this 1
billion word benchmark and get a huge
perplexity, you know, reduction.
And bear in mind that around that time,
you know, people were talking still
about n-gram models and maybe like
hybrid, uh, models, um, and this was the
the first definitive kind of result that
showed just pure or neural is clearly
the the way to go.
Okay, so life was very simple back then.
You train on the train split, you test
on the test split for perplexity.
So then when GPT-2 came around um in
2019 from OpenAI, um they trained on um
you know, the dataset called WebText,
which was 40 GB of text websites that
were linked from Reddit. Um
And the way they evaluated was actually
uh different. They evaluated
um
zero-shot on uh standard datasets that
everyone else was evaluating on.
Um so this is out of distribution
evaluation. So this is a table from
their paper which showed that as um they
trained different uh models. So the
biggest model is 1.5 uh billion
parameters.
Um and they were able to show um quite a
bit of um improvement, especially on the
uh small datasets. So for example, PTB,
which is a tiny dataset, um they were
getting 35 perplexity compared to the
state of the art, which is 46. Now, if
you have enough in-distribution data,
you don't quite do as well as the soda,
uh but you know, nonetheless, this is um
kind of impressive to given that this
model was not trained on 1 billion um
words uh dataset at all.
Um there might have I don't know, maybe
there was some overlap because you never
uh I don't know if they did a careful uh
train and test uh decontam.
Um
And and so this is
you know, ushered in a new
paradigm of thinking about language
models as not just kind of the I
in-distribution setting, but how we
wanted to train on a large dataset and
evaluate on standard benchmarks, which
nowadays I think is sort of been very
common standard, but um back then it was
um seen as a bit of a novelty.
So, um
I will also argue, since we're talking
about perplexity, that um perplexity is
all you all you need.
Um I wouldn't take this too seriously,
but I think it is a mindset. I think
that drives a lot of uh language
modeling research. And the basic
argument goes like this. So, there's
some true distribution out there, let's
call it T,
and you're training this model P.
So, what is the best perplexity you
could obtain?
Well, the best perplexity is the entropy
of that uh true distribution.
Um and that is realized when
P equals T.
Okay, so by minimizing um perplexity,
you're basically pushing down um
uh
you know, the perplexity, and the only
unique minimizer is when you actually
get the true distribution.
So, and when you have the true
distribution, you're you're done. You
just model everything, you can solve all
the problems, and you can do things like
condition on the problem, uh generate a
solution, you can condition on a
question, generate the answer.
Okay? So, by
pushing down on perplexity, we'll
eventually reach AGI is is the is the
argument.
I mean, this might sound, I don't know,
either a bit fantastical, but in some
sense, this is really, I think, a strong
driver of many people who have been
scaling and scaling language models, uh
at a time when maybe um
the
the gains weren't as obvious. Before
GPT-3, I think it wasn't clear that
language models were just going to have
such a huge
an impact, and it was really this belief
that if you drove perplexity down
good things will happen.
So,
you know, of course perplexity is maybe
not
all um
and why one way to frame it is that
perplexity is maybe more than you need.
So, for example, if you have a sentence
like Stanford was founded in 1885,
perplexity will say um penalize uh the
prediction on all tokens.
So, in particular, it'll say what is the
probability of 1885 given the rest. And
in that that token is probably pretty
useful. It's basically a Q&A uh example
um phrase is uh sentence completion.
So, it captures knowledge about uh the
world.
But other ones, for for example, the
first word of a sentence or even
founded, um maybe not that, you know,
interesting, I think. Um
And the perplexity doesn't care. It's
going to charge you uh
you know, bits for every, you know, bit
of uh deviation from the true
distribution.
So, there is a a bit of a solution here,
which is you can always measure the
conditional perplexity. You can
condition on some prompt and then you
can measure the um the perplexity of the
remaining response. So, that allows you
to in general focus on certain tokens
that you believe to be relevant um
and less on others that are sort of
incidental.
Okay.
So, and and also it's it's important to
remember that some benchmarks, even
though they are not explicitly a
perplexity measure, are actually just
perplexity in disguise. So, for example,
if you think about uh closed tasks, uh
there's this Lambada um paper um from
actually a while ago, 2016, which is
basically fill in the blank, blank, and
you have a a spurious context, you have
a sentence, "Do you honestly think I
will want you to have a blank?" And and
the goal is to figure out that that
word. And you know, even though this is
like measured in terms of accuracy, it
is really a a next token, you know,
prediction problem.
And here the it's not perplexity of all
the words, it's carefully chosen, if you
read this paper, it's really carefully
chosen to be words such that you
actually need
uh a bunch of long context to resolve.
Right? So, this is actually something
that the early GPT papers really uh
latched onto because they were
interested in
um
long context modeling, thinking that
that was a a key to unlocking kind of
reasoning and all these all these uh
things. And really by focusing on
positions where to to resolve that, it
requires um long uh
uh distance
uh dependencies um is a way to kind of
sharpen the um the perplexity to to some
phenomena that you care about.
Um here's another popular classic uh
data set that you see in some language
modeling valves, HellaSwag. Um so, what
is HellaSwag? They uh went to various
different, you know, data sets and
sources and came up with it. It's
multiple choice.
But, it's really sentence completion and
at some level it's it's perplexity. So,
here's a sentence, "A woman is outside
with a pug and a dog. The dog is running
around, she blank." And then you're
trying to fill in which sentence
completes it the best.
So, it's not exactly perplexity at
multiple choice, but um in some ways
it's it's perplexity.
So, one word of warning, if you ever
decide that you're going to you you're
sold on perplexity as as the really the
measure and you're going to launch a
leaderboard and have people compete
against perplexity, just a quick word of
caution
is that, you know, what does a
perplexity leaderboard look like? So,
people are going to submit a language
model to you
and
you have to compute log prop. You send
them the test data and they give you
back a log prop.
Well, you look at this and say, "Hmm,
that's a little bit might be a little
bit um fishy um because you need to
trust that the probabilities they hand
back
to you are are valid.
And that they sum to one. Otherwise, I
could just have implement LM and it
always returns
one
or I guess log prop zero.
And I would get very a good perplexity,
but um clearly that is
uh that's not a valid distribution.
And so, with this contract, it's not
really easy to check that someone is
actually internally having a log
probability, so there's some trust.
Maybe you have to look at the code or
something.
Um for downstream
tasks, uh this is much more
straightforward because you can have a
black box LM. I give you a prompt, you
give me a response and I can just use
that response and calculate some
accuracy.
So, perplexity is fundamentally
different because it deals with
distributions and you have to be a bit
careful.
And this is not to mention this isn't
less of a problem with auto regressive
models, but if you have like VAEs or um
there's some models where you can't even
compute the distribution, you can
compute only a a bound, then you have to
really actually trust the math as well
that this is actually a valid bound.
Okay.
So, the summary of perplexity is that
it is actually still used quite heavily
in language um
model
development. It has some nice
properties. We saw that it's generally
used for for scaling laws
because it's also smoothly varying with
scale, which is important for getting
scaling laws.
And
but you know, at the end of the day,
especially if you're not a believer,
then you need some benchmarks to really
capture real-world situations to
convince people that your language model
is good.
For the believers, if I show you a
remarkably slow perplexity, they'll be
they'll be convinced.
Okay, any questions about perplexity?
Okay, hopefully everyone's a believer
now.
Um
Okay, so let's talk about exam
benchmarks.
So exams, as as all your students know,
is a way that we use to test test humans
and so you can adopt the same mentality
to test language models.
Um the nice thing about exams is that
you have a very careful control over the
subject, over the difficulty.
Um
you can design them to have
unambiguous correct answers, which makes
them easy to grade.
So there's a lot of nice properties
about exams. And so for this reason, a
lot of LM benchmarking culture was based
on just this idea of exams.
So um
you know, obviously there's been a lot
of benchmarks, but I'll just highlight
some of the ones that I think are
have been influential in the development
of language models.
So this one is MMLU or massive multitask
language understanding from
Hendricks at all 2020.
Um and at that time,
you know, it wasn't clear that language
models were really like general purpose
task solvers. This was
um
around the time when GPT-3 came out.
Um many people I think still thought of
language models as as well language
models you generate fluent English. Uh
but they had this idea that well, let's
just try to be ahead of the curve here.
We're going to go through 57 subjects.
We're going to have a team of students
crawl scour the internet for different
sources and really put together this
very comprehensive um you know, data
set.
Um and despite the name MMLU which has
the word language understanding, it's
really about testing knowledge and
reasoning. It's less so just pure
language understanding.
And the way they evaluated it was with
GPT-3 on using few-shot prompting. So,
um
they essentially said, I have
formed this prompt. The following are
questions about high school mathematics,
some in-context examples of question
answer question answer and then the
final question and then the model has to
predict the answer.
So, this seems very mundane, but at that
time, it was I think pretty radical that
you would
construct this fairly complicated
question and with in-context examples
and everything and expect a language
model to actually do something
reasonable.
And sure enough at the at the outset,
the the models were not uh great, I
would say.
Um they were, you know, some of the
small models were barely above of of
chance and the larger model is GPT-3 was
actually well above chance. So, this was
um kind of encouraging.
Um and then over
uh the the years,
um
you know, as we we noted
uh
this benchmark has essentially, you
know, uh saturated. So, this is a site.
I don't think this has all the the data
in it, but, you know, about 3.5 turbo.
This was like um 20 20
I guess beginning of 2024 or 23
actually,
um to GPT-4, and then now the
you know, now it's on in the '90s.
Okay?
So, um
there's also a link you can follow up um
later on where you can actually browse
some of the predictions of these models,
which is um always fun to see what
models actually uh goof up on and what
they get right.
Okay, so, um
So, around 2024, when it was it seemed
like MMLU, there was a lot of progress
made.
It's like, okay, uh you're going to see
this thing again. Okay, this this
benchmark is getting too easy.
Uh let's let's try to make it harder.
So, um
well, first of all, they actually
noticed that there were some noisy and
trivial problems, so let's get rid of
them. Uh four choices might be a little
bit too too easy, so let's expand that
to 10. Um
at that point, um it was much more in
vogue to use chain of thought to solve
these benchmarks, whereas when GPT-3
came out, um that didn't wasn't really a
thing.
Um
and it's clear that some of these
questions uh could benefit from a few
reasoning steps.
Um so, this new benchmark uh
was harder, so now the accuracy of the
models is back at 33. Um but, as you can
maybe see from the progress so far,
um
you know, it's it's started low and now
it's uh back to I guess it's like 88,
almost 90.
Okay, so this benchmark might be a
little bit um
you know, too easy as well.
Okay, so there's another benchmark
called uh GPQA, which stands for uh
Google Proof uh QA.
Um
and
the idea here is that, okay, how can we
get a really uh good, you know, you
know, benchmark? And the idea is that,
well, if you can solve a problem by
looking at Google, Google has kind of
the internet and the language model is
trained on the internet, so may- if you
can just solve it, then that's probably
too easy. So, they got some uh now, you
know, PhD level, so I think MMLU was
think about like as um
actually, some of these
maybe it some of these were like
undergrad, um but maybe grad um level,
but now it's more explicitly about
questions that are meant to be um pretty
hard. And at this point now, you say,
okay, how do I come up with really hard
questions? You actually have to go
through quite a bit of human labor to
get really hard questions. So, this was
61 PhD contractors from Upwork. Um
someone writes a question, it goes
through uh expert validation, which then
provides feedback on the questions, um
and then the question writer goes and
revises the question, and then another
expert looks at the question, and then
you go to um you have the
uh the question, and then you send it to
some non-experts who are given
uh at Google access, and then you see if
they can solve the question.
So, there's a subset of these questions
called the diamond uh set that you might
see um in um
you know, people's uh leaderboards,
where if the two experts agree, and at
most one of the non-experts is able to
answer the question, then that's deemed
a good or kind of diamond question.
So, this is pretty kind of rigorous
review process.
Um, and um, PhD experts were only able
to um
get a 65%
so this is I think mostly four-way
multiple choice. So,
um, this is above random but you know,
this is not a good grade if you're
getting 65% on an exam. Um
and uh, it's non-experts even if they
had 30 minutes with access to Google
they're getting
um, about a bit over chance but not
much. And at that point uh, GPT-4 was
like 39% and let's see how how it's
doing now.
Um
so GBQA is now again
uh, 94 okay, 94.
So yeah, so these benchmarks are um,
have a shelf life of not too uh, high I
guess.
Um, I would say that some of these
benchmarks even though they saturate the
large and smalls they're still useful
for developing smaller models or fitting
scaling laws and and so on.
Okay, so then um, yeah.
>> So,
how do you know that
when these going to start being used for
training and actually your
models have good knowledge
>> Yeah, so this is a very important
question. So, how do you know that uh,
these questions aren't just in the uh,
training set? Um, so the short answer is
we don't know um, because I don't know
what's in the training set.
Um, I'll come back to this contamination
point a little bit later and ways of
addressing it but you should always it's
I'm glad you asked this. You guys should
always take these numbers with a little
bit of grain of salt because
um, it's only trust.
Um, I I maybe just to say one more. I
think training contamination is is a
little bit subtle, right? Because it's
probably not the case that they
literally train on the set, but you
know, questions can be derived from
other sources and those sources could be
trained on. So, often contamination is a
much more um subtle process than
literally accidentally training on the
test.
Uh was there another question?
>> The same question.
>> Okay. Great.
Good. It's always good to be skeptical.
Okay. So, the final um exam benchmark
I'll talk about is something ominously
called uh Humanities Last Exam.
Um this is from last year.
And they were saying, "Okay, well, these
models are getting so good. Let's just
give it all we can to create something
that's really tough."
Um so, this is multimodal, many
subjects. It's still multiple choice and
I guess some short answer.
And so, this was uh you know, uh
crowd-sourced. Uh they had some money to
incentivize
um
uh people who were into money to create
questions. They also incentivized with
authorship for those who were into that.
Um
and they went through multiple stages of
reviews filtered by frontier models.
Um there's a whole process.
Uh another answer to your question is
that they also held out a private set
that was not released publicly so that
um they could make sure that this did
not enter, you know, training.
And then you just hope that the APIs
that uh you because you still have to
send this to the model, that those
prompts don't end up in the training. Um
but let's let's hope that's the case.
Um so, this, you know, every data set
paper kind of looks like this. Previous
benchmarks, look, the models are doing
so well. My data set, look, all the
models are doing really poorly. So, this
is a a kind of plum and powder, and this
was especially like single digits. It's
It's pretty abysmal here.
Um and let's see how we're doing
um in 2026.
So,
this one is It still has some room. So,
it's only at Even Methos is only at
64.7.
Okay. So, this is indeed a pretty It
seems like a pretty hard uh
exam.
Okay.
So, to summarize the section,
as you can see, we've trained it towards
harder and harder questions as the
models improve and we saturate existing
benchmarks.
It's interesting that multiple-choice
format still survives um because uh it's
you with multiple choice, I mean, you
can make it as difficult as you want.
Right. So, the the Some people think
that well, multiple choice is too easy.
Well, I mean, I can give you a very hard
multiple-choice
uh you know, question. That's not really
the point. Um
I think the more the point is that
multiple choice restricts the set of
questions you can ask, but in terms of
difficulty, no problem with multiple
choice.
The main problem with uh exam-based
um questions is that this does not
capture real-world usage.
Um no one asks HLE questions to
uh to a language model, except for when
you're evaluating uh HLE.
Um most of the time, people are asking
open-ended questions.
Um They don't even necessarily have a
correct answer. They might not be
well-formed. And uh these benchmarks do
not capture that.
Okay. So,
question.
>> So, for accuracy, how is the model
output compared with the ground truth
answer?
>> So, for HLE,
>> Like, for accuracy, like, how is the
model's output compared with the ground
truth answer?
>> For accuracy, to calculate the accuracy.
>> Of calculate the accuracy for how is the
ground truth compared? So,
um
for multiple choice, it's just like did
you get the right answer?
>> So, like would we check the probability
of the solution for each option or like
how is
>> Um so, the language model
generates a like C. And my answer is
either B or C or A or D, and I just
check if they're the the same or not.
>> Okay, so you're you're only generating
one token.
The language
>> Yes. Well, okay. So, then the question
is less about evaluation, but how does
the model generate an answer? Right? So,
there's a few options. One is that you
generate um
literally you sample and it generates a
letter. Or uh more commonly now you
generate a chain of thought, you
generate the answer, maybe some
explanation. Um but there is a way of
extracting an answer, which um
you know, does matter.
And and language model evaluations can
be very sensitive to that, but I'm not
going to talk about that here.
Okay. So, let's talk about a very
different class of benchmarks uh called
uh chat benchmarks.
Um so, so far we've talked about
multiple choice tasks. So, they're still
pretty good at capturing um some notion
of intelligence and difficulty. Um but
most people don't ask a multiple choice
exam question to their AI assistant
unless they're trying to use their AI
assistant to do their exam for them,
which you would never No one does that.
Um okay. So,
So, here's an example um
semi-inspired by a real-world uh use
case. So, you know, I might say I want
to make a beet salad, which is what
herbs will work well and what won't work
well.
Okay, so this is a very open-ended
question and then you get some response
which is
again an open-ended
response. And then the question is how
do you evaluate this thing?
Right, you can't just check exact match
with equality. There's no ground truth
even.
So there's a few ideas here.
We we should go through them. So
one of the ideas is was pioneered by
this chatbot arena.
And the idea is well you ask humans.
Okay.
Um
But the way they ask humans I think is a
kind of a clever idea. So they basically
had the set of this website where any
random person from the internet can go
in and chat.
Um and then instead of like a normal as
a assistant and getting one response,
you actually get two responses
from two different models which are
anonymized.
And then they rate which one is better.
So for example, you put in this
response, you get these two assistant A,
assistant B, and then you ask A is
better, both are good, both are bad, B
is better.
Okay?
So using this process
you can get a bunch of pairwise
comparison data of model A, model B you
know, which one is better.
And then you can use this compute ELO
rankings based on this. So just as I
don't know how many of you are familiar
with this, but just as kind of a
just to get everyone on the same page
in these ELO rankings you define your
your rating model as a probability of
a particular model beating another
model as
some function
of the ELO scores of model B and model
A.
So the larger uh model
uh ELO score of A is, the higher the
probability. So, it's a smooth mapping.
And then, you fit this model
with the parameters, which are the ELO
ratings, to maximize the probability of
the pairwise comparisons.
Okay? And then, as a result, you
basically get a rate rating for each of
your models.
Okay? So, this is what um Chatbot Arena,
nowadays known as uh Arena AI, uh did.
And you can get this uh kind of nice uh
ranking. Um
I guess Claude Opus is doing pretty well
here.
Um
but, you know, some other models are on
the list as well.
Okay.
So, there's a few things that are nice
about the setup. One is that
um
you have real-world prompts.
Right? So, the idea is that anyone can
come to the site, and the incentive for
someone to come to the site is that they
get free access to a language model. And
so, there's sort of this implicit
assumption that they're actually trying
to use it to do something useful, and
therefore, you get sort of like um a um
you know, a real-world prompt. Um
But, one thing you should keep in mind
is, you know, who are these people?
Like, random person on the internet is
uh I don't know I don't know what that
distribution random person on the
internet who comes to LLM Arena, I don't
know what that distribution, you know,
looks like. I think in their paper, they
have some demographics, but, you know,
demographics don't tell the whole story.
Um you could worry about different
biases coming from the different um
models, maybe spammers, people are
trying to uh game um
you know, who maybe even submitted a
model, and they want to their model to
look uh good. Um
You know, you just don't know. It's a
little bit of a wild west.
Um
there's another issue, which is that,
you know, the binary preference, which
is better, A or B,
is very nice and simple and feeds into
this uh um
rating, but it does conflate style and
uh correctness.
So, Elo ratings for chess makes a lot of
sense because the only thing that
matters is did you win? But, you know,
which um which one is better is is much
uh less clear-cut.
And um
you know, there's questions of, you
know, the human is the judge here. The
person who puts in the prompt is
answering the question, and this is good
because in some level, because the the
person is um
has some intent, and they can sort of
declare whether their intent was met.
To some extent, except for they're
presumably asking the question because
they don't know the answer. So, if I
give you two answers,
how are they to judge
uh judge which one's correct?
And then there's also the problem of
sycophancy where um maybe um more
pleasing answers are going to be um
upweighted highly compared to uh correct
but honest answers.
So, there's a lot of uh kind of
potential issues um here.
Um but the nice thing about this method,
which is that you don't need to feed the
same prompts to all the models. And this
is the beauty of Elo, right? In chess,
you don't have to play everyone plays
everyone else.
Um it can just be kind of some sparse
sample of that, and you can still derive
rankings as long as the graph is kind of
connected. Um and this is important
because human is rating, and you can't
expect a human to rate like all the
models or even more than two models.
Um and the nice thing as well is that as
new prompts and new models come in,
there's a natural story for making um
this updating over time.
Okay, so
um let me talk about a different
approach.
Uh
So this is AlpacaEval from 2023.
There were some instructions from
various
you know derived from various sources.
Um
Um and the metric here is
you know, the win rate against a
baseline model. So you have a model.
AlpacaEval says, I'm going to generate
it for a prompt. Generate using let's
say a baseline model GPT-4 preview at
that time. And then judge using GPT
preview which one is better.
So immediately this raises a question of
you know, potential bias. But let's put
that aside for now.
So this is basically as instantiation of
LLM as a judge, which is very popular
these days for evaluating language
models. Um and you can mitigate this
bias by having multiple judges and
ensembling and so on and so forth.
So one problem with initially AlpacaEval
is that LLM judges favor long responses.
And this will lead to a bunch of
leaderboard gaming where a bunch of
models that were fine-tuned were
submitted and they got really high LLM
AlpacaEval performance just because the
responses were longer. So this got fixed
in a subsequent paper where
they use a very simple regression method
to debias the metric.
Okay, so but there's a this raises a
kind of a more general question here,
which is not actually specific to
AlpacaEval, which is how do you evaluate
a metric?
Okay, so we're talking about we've been
talking about evaluation of models. And
if I have a metric, I can evaluate a
model. But if I'm coming up with a new
metric, how do I know this metric is any
good?
So this is uh
hard problem and there's no
no answer here.
Um one thing you can do is more of a
sanity check is you can look at
correlation with other metrics.
Um with a idea that
higher isn't necessarily, you know,
better in all cases unless you are
trying to mimic this other metric. So,
um Alpaca Eval
uh correlation with uh Chatbot Arena is
0.98, which is uh quite high.
So, which suggests that um
you could, let's say you wanted to um
um evaluate on a Chatbot Arena, but
you're
uh I don't know, too shy to put your
model, or you don't want to wait for
humans, or whatever, you can use Alpaca
Eval uh to evaluate um instead.
Now, this correlation, of course, is
with respect to a certain set of models,
and and so this might not hold for uh
models that, let's say, are stronger
than GPT-4 uh preview.
Okay. So, at this point, this
leaderboard, I don't think is uh really
um
yeah, hasn't been maintained in over a
over a year, but uh this is kind of what
it looked like at the time.
Okay. So, there's another uh
um benchmark I'll I'll talk about, which
is WildBench, and this one um
was sourced a bunch of examples from
human uh chatbot conversations. So, like
uh
uh Chatbot Arena, they also put up a
free service where people could chat
with this bot, and they collected the um
the the the the queries.
And then, uh like uh Alpaca Eval, they
um
used a LLM as a judge
to evaluate um the
the the model.
Um the main innovation here is the use
of a a checklist
which is generated and specific to a
particular
um prompt or or task. And the idea here
is that if you just ask a language model
to judge whether
this prompt is this response is good or
not,
this is in some sense a very ill-defined
task. Like I don't know what depends on
what you care about. And so the idea
here is that by having a checklist or
some sort of rubric, this greatly kind
of scopes and makes the task evaluation
task more well-defined.
Um so
they did this this also. They showed
correlation with uh Chatbot Arena, which
uh admittedly is a little bit kind of
you know, circular because then you can
ask why well, is Chatbot Arena really
the ground truth? But at least we're all
in the same boat together. Um
So
Okay, so to conclude this section, um
how do you evaluate open-ended
responses?
Um
you know, not
there's no clear
uh solution here, but there's some
ideas. Pairwise comparisons
between a reference and a
a um
a model response is generally a good
idea because um especially for very
similar responses, you can kind of give
directional information. Well, this one
slightly better than this, but in terms
of absolute ranking, like is this a
seven out of 10 or an eight out of 10?
That tends to be a lot less uh high
signal.
Um one should always be aware of biases
both in terms of humans or LM judges.
They have different biases, but
nonetheless, um
that's something important to uh you
know, pay attention to. Perhaps the only
thing you might be able to do is you
evaluate over multiple judges, humans,
and judges and of all everything is
saying your model is better than
maybe your model is better.
And finally,
the evaluation problem here of
open-ended response, I would emphasize
is not really well-defined.
And so, increasingly, I think it's
important to define, you know, rubrics
or checklists to to improve the
reliability or uh
um
you know,
well-definedness of an actual
evaluation. And this is true regardless
of a human and a judge. So, anyone who's
done crowdsourcing knows that if you
just ask a human to rate something
without giving some sort of rubric,
you're probably going to get very um
nonsensical results.
Okay. So,
um
let's move on to
the agentic uh world. So, you can think
about what we've been doing so far is
um
evaluating what a language model is say,
and that's chat. And now, we're going to
evaluate what LLMs do, which is, you
know, agents.
And um so,
you know, um for anyone who's following
um AI hype, um you know, agents are
everywhere and, you know, these are
definitely,
I think, going to transform the way that
we think about um
you know, language models.
So, agent is basically a language model
plus some sort of scaffold, which is uh
a logic for deciding how the language
model
um is going to be called and what tools
it can has access to and so on and so
forth.
Um
so, there's a few benchmarks I want to
just um you know, point out um that are
agentic.
So, uh one is um you know, very popular,
It's just called SWE bench.
Um,
there's
Basically, the task is you're given a
code base and a description of a GitHub
issue, submit a PR. And the way you
evaluate a PR is uh whether it passes uh
the unit tests. So, this these tests are
designed so that before you submit a PR,
certain unit tests don't pass, and then
your goal is to fix it. So, certain unit
tests pass and you don't break anything
else. So, here's an example of uh some
instructions. Here's the issue.
Um,
and then some code uh that is provided
in the context. And then your goal is to
generate a patch. And given a patch, uh
you are evaluated um on whether you pass
or not.
So, the good thing about this is that uh
the evaluation is very straightforward.
Um, and
let's see how we're doing on
um
SWE bench.
Actually, this is going to be SWE bench
verified, which later I'll show you um
tell you why
this happened.
Um, so SWE bench uh in this was only, I
guess, 2024
was still around um you know, 16% and
now it's up to like 93. Good job,
Mythos. Okay.
So,
um
Okay. So, this is uh sort of a very
canonical a a generic benchmark. As a
lot of uh attention on agents has been
invested in in coding abilities. So, SWE
bench really kind of pioneered this uh
this way of thinking about how to assess
an agent's ability to write and code in
a realistic uh environment.
So, here's another uh a project called
uh Terminal Bench.
And here the idea is that
um this is going to be more
general-purpose, right? And we're going
to basically have the environment be a
computer terminal.
And we're going to define a bunch of
tasks
um that can be done in a computer
terminal by, you know, uh typing in a
bunch of commands.
And the nice thing about this
environment is a very simple and and
universal.
Um
so
um
and these uh tasks were crowdsourced
from, you know, uh
93 people from, you know, across the
across the world. Um 89 of these tasks
are, you know, uh constitute Terminal
Bench 2.0. Um these tasks generally take
uh for um
you know, it's ranging from 1 hour to
over a week, depending on whether you're
expert or uh junior.
Um and then here's what the leaderboard
looks like as of uh you know, today. Um
so top models are um you know, the
frontier models. One thing that's
interesting is that, you know, the agent
um is also um kind of important here.
Because you can have two
uh
agents, but the same model, and they
have different, you know, accuracies.
Um okay, so another benchmark I'll talk
about is uh you know, cyber uh security.
So this is
um 40 capture-the-flag tasks. And the
setting here is that um you have an
agent that is given an
an environment um and it can run uh
various um commands like, you know, look
at the source code. It can um
it can uh run um you know, access the
web server. And the goal is essentially
hack into this uh server to extract some
flag, which is a unique string that
proves that you've hacked into the
server.
Um so these are competitions cyber
security exercises that um are done by
humans normally. And um
the
um
this this is an example of what the the
agent uh
scaffold kind of looks like here. This
is a very simplistic um version where
basically you have one continuous
memory.
Um you you produce some sort of action.
Uh you get environment feedback and then
you uh put the results into this buffer
and this is concatenated. Um as I'll
show you later, this is actually um
you know, this this history obviously
grows quite a bit and you'll need to um
you kind of uh have better ways of
managing context.
Um okay, so this is what the leaderboard
looks like when it came out. You know,
the best models were like about 10% or
so and over time now um it's completely
solved actually. Uh
So that's uh that's I bench. Uh there's
another class of problems which are MLE
engineering.
Um
So the this is uh this benchmark has a
bunch of Kaggle competitions which
involve processing data, training
models, and so on and so forth.
And the agent uh
can look at the data set, read the
description, write code, um train
models, and um you eventually submit
something and you get a grade.
Um so this is what the the leaderboard
uh looks like right now. And again, you
can see that it's really the same usual
suspects on on the LM side. Um but
there's quite a bit of variation in
terms of the the different agents uh
scaffolds.
So one thing to note about I'll point
out about agents uh scaffolds is that uh
um
they matter a lot. Um so,
um when I talk said I talk about
language model evaluation,
um this is
broader than language model evaluation.
And the reason is that, you know, unlike
what I mentioned before with uh this
this early
side bench agent scaffold, now you have
to be a lot more sophisticated to solve
really complicated tasks.
Um
one thing that people
realized is that explicit planning is
helpful. You can't just kind of stream
of conscious chain of thought this and
then um you build up this context and
the agent can easily lose track of where
it is. So, instead keep a to-do list,
get it checked off. Um
hierarchical delegation,
um agents should call other sub-agents
with some cleaned context. It do- it
that
agent does some stuff and returns only
the result. The the master agent doesn't
need to see all the the gory details.
And this can help encapsulate provide
some encapsulation.
Um um memory, uh people have been
experimenting around with explicitly
reading and writing files, especially as
the context grows. You can't just store
it in
um your your context window.
Um and then finally,
there is more context engineering in the
style of managing the process. You know,
when should you delegate to sub-agents?
How when to kind of try this strategy
versus uh this other strategy? What to
write to persistent memory? And these
things um are generally um
you know, uh optimized for uh the
particular um language model.
Okay, so agents are exciting because
they enhance the capability surface of
language models. Scaffolds are very
important. So, really when we talk about
evaluating agents, it's evaluating both
the language model and the agent
scaffold.
Okay. Now, we're going to switch gears a
little bit and talk about this other
very different style of benchmarks.
I call them pure reasoning for lack of,
I think, better term.
And the motivation is that all the tasks
so far require some linguistic and world
knowledge.
And so, the question is, can we just
isolate
reasoning or pure kind of fluid
intelligence from a knowledge and
knowing facts?
And you can argue that this gives you a
form of more pure
intelligence.
So, there was this project uh
uh ARC-AGI
which is
started back in 2019
where um the goal was exactly this.
So, um this the the task was
meant to be 100% solvable by humans, but
challenging for AIs. And every task is
sort of a special snowflake, or that's
the intent. And so, memorizing a bunch
of facts or solving previous problems
um shouldn't really help you that much.
So, if you guys are remembering your LM
history, 2019
was pre-LM. I mean, this was GPT-2 era.
Um so, this was kind of um prescient in
that regard. So, here's an example of
the first iteration of a problem. You're
given these um these pictures, and
you're trying to guess what comes next.
And if you take like 10 seconds, you can
probably solve this
problem.
Okay. So, you know, you probably guess
it's to just fill in the the yellow to
form the the rectangle.
Um okay. so then
and uh last year, there's a updated
version of this task, which was a bit
more complicated.
Um,
and you can take a look at this.
so here's a
the trajectory. So
when ARC-AGI 1 came out, um,
you know, the I think this is actually
zero. Um, so basically models didn't do
anything. So this is like GPT-3
pre-trained models didn't move the
needle at all.
Right? And this was exactly as the
creators had intended. Pre-trained
models just, you know,
like learn what the facts are on the
internet and maybe learn linguistic
patterns, but none of that is actually
helpful, um,
directly at least for, um, the these
ARC-AGI tasks.
And then something happened in 2024.
And this is when OpenAI released their
01 and 03 models, then things started
taking off pretty abruptly.
And now it our
AGI ARC-AGI 1 is basically solved. Um,
and even around 2025,
um,
when ARC-AGI 2 came out, this has also,
you know, it's not quite solved, but,
you know, it looks like it's on its way
to being, um, solved.
So it was really the the reasoning
capability that kind of unlocked, um,
um, this. And now one could wonder
whether, um, all the
the knowledge of of actual pre-training,
um, was was necessary for these tasks.
And certainly, you know, without
pre-training, we wouldn't have this
explosion of reasoning models. So
arguably, it was, uh, still important,
but not maybe, uh, directly visible for
much of the history of ARC-AGI.
So now just last month ARC AGI 3 comes
out. So you see this familiar pattern.
All of creators look at this and like,
"Oh, oh, time for a new benchmark." Um
so this is now an interactive
environment.
Um where you can go on uh line and you
can play this game. So again, no
language. You're just trying to kind of
figure out based on patterns.
Um it's kind of fun. Um and now the
scores are extremely low. So so next
year when I teach this class, um I'm
sure I'll have to update this uh this
slide, but we'll see.
So I think this uh ARC AGI line is is is
a really kind of interesting to think
about. Um the goal is to disentangle
reasoning from knowledge.
This is really hard to do. And you know,
it's not
I think this is probably the best
attempt at this. It's not clear whether
you can really fully uh decouple things.
Um and certainly if
you know, if people really cared about
this benchmark, I think people probably
could you know, people can benchmark I
think probably anything. So you could
design questions like are these. These
still come from some prior. Um and
you know, not sure there's anything as
kind of quote unquote pure as as
reasoning.
This is also constrained to human
reasoning. The explicit goal is to be
100% human solvable within some
reasonable time.
Um so this doesn't uh really extend to
human superhuman reasoning. For example,
solving winning IMO gold medals or
solving open math problems, which
arguably are still very useful and
important.
But clearly this exposes some gaps in
the current models. So there is kind of
work to do if you think about the goal
is basically being able to uh solve all
the tasks.
Yeah.
>> Well, this
graphic
So this ARC AGI 3 especially looks quite
graphic. So
uh is there a some multi-modal content
involved or including
or
as a textual representation as well?
>> Yeah, so question is this looks very
graphic
graphical
and so what is input to our language
models? So this is essentially I don't
know whether I think it's 64 by 64. So
you can provide this image or you can
provide it in like ASCII art or or some
sort of textual representation.
Um
either way there is a sort of spatial
element here that the model has to
reason about which is
really not English or natural language.
Okay, so let's talk about shift gears
and talk about another class of
benchmarks which is related to safety.
Um so people have been talking about
safety in language models for for a
while and if you think about other areas
such as cars
it's pretty clear what safety means
here, right? There is
you know these
uh ratings for safety ratings for cars
which involve you know testing based on
smashing cars into a wall with a airbag
and seeing how how well it it does and
protects the you know the the the
dummies in the in the car and and this
is with you know decades of lobbying and
figuring out what safety means for
vehicles. So what does it mean for AI?
So I would say that there is not a great
answer here, but I'll give you some
examples of what people have been
thinking about.
So there's this benchmark called you
know harm bench and this is really about
um
you know prompting a model with things
that are meant to
be harmful and expecting the the model
to essentially refuse.
Um so this is one, you know, type of
safety and I think
probably the dominant thing when people
think about safety is that I want to
prevent bad actors from doing things
with uh language models. But it turns
out that's not the only thing that
matters. So there's this other work,
Airbench, which um
tries to think about safety holistically
by looking at all the regulatory
frameworks in the EU, China, and uh the
the US,
company policies, and builds a taxonomy
of all the different things that could
go wrong.
Um and then using this, constructing a
particular um set of prompts and um
and evaluating, so on and so forth.
Um
but one problem with safety is uh you
know, jailbreaking, which is its own
kind of sub problem,
which is that language models are
generally trained to refuse harmful
instructions,
but
as we we know, you can get around this
if you're clever.
And so there's some early work that uses
automatic ways to um
optimize for prompts to bypass uh safety
using
um
you know, GCG, which is basically this
uh kind of uh coordinate-wise
optimization algorithm.
And remarkably, um optimizing on open
models
uh allows us to transfer to models. So
this is this I hope this doesn't These
attacks don't work anymore, but um at
the time,
um you can generate some basically
gibberish um
and step step-by-step plan to destroy
humanity, and uh um
Open AI's model will, you know, comply.
Um obviously, you could argue, "Well, is
this actually a
you know, harmful plan to destroy
humanity?" But that's At least uh it did
not The expected behavior is that it
should probably refuse that.
Okay.
So, this raises a kind of a bigger
problem, which is what is, you know,
safety?
And one thing that makes this tricky is
that many aspects of safety are very
contextual. So, you know, the involves,
you know, politics, laws, social norms.
This stuff varies across different
countries.
And then also, if you think about
safety, you have to think about what are
the risks?
Um
And the risks are actually
quite varied as as well and demand
probably different attention. So,
hallucinations is a risk, especially,
let's say, medical or uh you know, legal
or financial settings.
Um but this is also correlated with just
capabilities. Like if you make a model
more accurate, um it's correlated with
not hallucinating as much. Sickle fancy
is is a problem.
Um you know, betting crimes is a
problem, but this is This might be
uh counter to um capabilities.
Inequality,
um you know, losing critical thinking
might be uh a you know, a risk as well
that's uh correlated with capabilities.
So,
you know, the If you think about the
societal impact of language models on on
the world and
um and think about safety is ensuring
that AI goes well for people. This is
actually um a much more complex uh topic
than I'll have time to, you know, talk
about. And finally, there is a dual use
aspect of uh language models. So, the
cybersecurity agents can be used to hack
into a system or to do penetration
testing and make systems more secure,
which makes talking about
whether these are safety risks or
actually beneficial um a double-edged
sword.
Okay. So,
let's move on now to talk about some,
you know, broader considerations of
evaluation. So,
one thing that, um, I think is an
important aspect of evaluation is
realism or ecological validity.
How well does the evaluation capture
real-world use?
So, in particular, exams are very far
away from real-world, uh, use.
Um,
you know, chat about arena are from real
people,
but, you know, one could wonder whether
this distribution is the right
distribution of of people or use cases
or not.
There's a few, uh, benchmarks I'll, uh,
mention that try to get a ecological,
uh, validity and in particular at the
sort of the use case level, at least,
not their individual query level.
So, there's this, uh, OpenAI, um,
created benchmark called GDP Val. They
looked at all the top sec- nine sectors
according to US GDP, got a bunch of
professionals
to, uh, create tasks. Um, these are
professionals with like, you know, about
14 years of experience. And you can see
people who are nurses, who work, you
know, concierge, real estate agents,
film and video editors, and and so on
and so forth. And they created a bunch
of, uh, you know, tasks.
Um,
here's another example, um, in the
medical domain where,
um,
up until this point, a lot of medical
benchmarks were based on standardized
exams.
And in fact, actually, for humans, this
is also what what, you know, happens.
You take these, uh, standardized exams
and, you know, you you graduate from med
school and then you go operate on, uh,
well, actually, there's a longer
process. You don't operate on patients
directly.
But, um,
so,
but the point is that for a language
model, you should also not just like uh,
pass medical exams and um, deploy them
directly. So, this was
a project where um you know
121 tasks were sourced from 29
clinicians. Um and this was meant to
represent the type of things that
clinicians would actually ask to a
language model, which are quite
different than
the multiple-choice type of exam
questions.
Um here's another uh project which is uh
gets at real data. So, you know, if you
ask who actually has the data on what
people are doing, what's the the model
developers.
And so, this project is interesting
because it uses um
uh language models themselves to analyze
real data.
So, in particular, you due to privacy,
you can't literally go and
uh
look at people's data, but you can have
language models
look at the data and analyze and
summarize uh general patterns. So, then
the language models could tell you about
what are the types of people
um what are the types of things that
people use uh Claude for.
Um
you know, and sometimes, you know, uh
realism and privacy are at with each
other because ideally, you would want
actually uh uh sample from the actual
query stream, and that would be very
valuable to assess how well a model is
working and understand deeply what the
errors are, but then that runs into
privacy uh considerations.
Okay. So, another consideration, which
is another type of valid validity, is um
you know, just in general, how do we
know that the evaluations are
scientifically valid?
And this was brought up fairly early,
train task overlap or for
So, in a machine learning 101,
you learn don't train on your test set.
Hopefully.
Um
And before foundation models, this was
actually pretty
clear. Um right? So, with like ImageNet
and Squad and many benchmarks,
uh sort of data sets, there was always a
train split and a test split, and
everyone played the same game. You train
on your training data, you test on your
test data.
Um life was simple.
And now you have these models that are
trained on the internet and much more
than that. And uh furthermore, you don't
know what's in the data. So, um this
makes evaluation quite different, I
think.
So, what can you do in this?
So,
first thing you can do is you can be try
to infer whether a model has actually
seen the test data. Um so, this is a uh
an a neat idea
uh from Tatsuo's group that um where you
leverage the fact that
um the order in which the questions in a
benchmark uh occurs is should be random.
But, if the model prefers some sort of
particular order that's consistent with
a benchmark, that is probably it just
like trained on that um you know,
benchmark.
Um another route is that you can
encourage people to report um
you know, uh
you know, uh actual train test overlap.
So,
this has to do with norms, right? I
think in in general, especially maybe
less in machine learning, but more in
statistics,
um
you always report confidence uh
intervals, right? You have an estimate,
and I always want to know like how
reliable is that estimate. This is just
standard practice.
And so, uh the idea of this, you know,
position paper is that you should model
providers, if you're going to claim some
GPQA score, you should always provide
some
justification that
um
you know, you didn't train on the test
set.
Um
So, another route is that where you can
just give up. It's like, "Okay, all
these evaluations, they're
let's just assume that people trained on
them. Assume the worst case." And
so, the thing that we have on our side
is that you can always define fresh
evals. So, there's a bunch of um ideas,
like Code Bench, Untreated Eval, which
basically scrape new webpages or archive
papers or uh GitHub, and defines
evaluations that are past the cutoff
date of the language models.
So, this seems pretty robust and good.
But, one thing to keep in mind is that
timestamps always safe either, because
I might post a or, you know, um
you know, if with code, for example, I
might put something on GitHub, and which
is actually derived from like some other
repo. And so, how do I know that that's
actually generally fresh?
Um route four is to use uh private
evaluations. So, companies, uh model
developers do this, right? So, if you're
Google or OpenAI, you have your internal
codebase, which you assume is not on the
internet, and you obviously wouldn't
train on this uh this this data.
Um so, you can use it for evaluation.
So, this generally is pretty reliable.
Um and if you're not uh a company, you
can use your personal writings.
Um I have a bunch of rejected papers
from, you know, when I was in grad
school that I never put on online, so I
can use those.
Um
And in the night this
type of evaluation I think is very
favorable for perplexity
evals because all you need in perplexity
is just you need a good, you know, data
set and you can evaluate log
probabilities.
So, another uh
concern um that I'll mention is data set
quality.
Um so, remember I
showed the leaderboard for SweetBench uh
and you know, verified.
Um this is because, you know, well,
SweetBench had uh a bunch of, you know,
problems of tasks that weren't, you
know, the unit tests that weren't uh
quite uh rigorous enough and other
things that got, you know, fixed.
Um and
you know, there are many other
benchmarks um
um that have gone through this process
like like Gia GSM8K or MMLU where um
you know, people have gone and done a
more careful audit and realized that,
"Wait a minute, this question actually
doesn't
is something's broken around this
question."
Okay? So, like this one, there's there's
no curve given in this this text, so you
can't answer this question.
Um
you know, does the baby have socks on?
You know, there's no way to tell.
Okay? So,
um
and there's also this paper that showed
that there's a lot of problems with the
genetic benchmarks, which arguably are
even harder to assess because it's not
just you can look at the question and
the
possible answers and you can look at it,
but it's a whole environment.
Um and there are cases where
you know, with coding you can it's great
to have test cases that either pass or
not pass, but as we all know, test cases
can be incomplete. So, you might pass
all the test cases, but still not have a
working solution.
Um there's another case of this the
where they show that if an agent just uh
outputs the empty response, they can get
like a 38%.
So, there are some trivialities with
these benchmarks um that you one has to
be very careful to avoid.
One thing I'll call out is that there's
this tool uh called uh Docent that uses
language models to inspect agent traces
to detect problems.
Um so, this is kind of a qualitative
response to our very quantitative heavy
way of benchmarking.
And I would always recommend that
whenever you do a benchmark, um either
divide develop a benchmark or run a um a
model on the
benchmark, that you always look at the
output and try to audit it to make sure
that you actually think you're measuring
what you think you're measuring.
Okay. So,
you know, maybe getting a bit more
philosophical. So, what's the point of
evaluation?
Okay. So, I've talked a lot about
different types of evaluation. And
really there's no one evaluation to rule
them all. And I think it's when you
think about evaluation, you have to be
very clear about what the purpose is,
and I think often this is not uh really
stated clearly.
So, for example, you could be a
you know, user or company that's trying
to decide make a purchase decision. Are
you going to go with A or B for a
particular use case?
Or you're just a researcher, and you
have this intuitive notion of
intelligence, and you want to measure it
somehow. Or you want to understand the
benefits and harms for business or
policy reasons. Or you're a model
developer, and you want to get feedback
to improve the model.
So, each of these goals will lead you to
potentially different um um you know,
benchmarks or some combination of
evaluation strategies.
And finally, one thing to um address,
which I hinted at briefly, is that what
are we even evaluating? So, before
foundation models, uh researchers
evaluated methods because we have these
train test splits, and the only thing
that was varying is the actual
algorithm.
And today, we're mostly evaluating
models and systems where anything goes.
Um you know, there are some exceptions.
So, the nano GPT speedrun is a
deliberately a way to evaluate an
algorithm um in particular how well fast
you can train a model, but most of uh
language model uh evaluation is about
evaluating the actual end model, which
is useful because that is the thing that
is actually going to get shipped and
people are going to use. But, I think
the the punchline is that you should
always be very deliberate about um
saying uh
declaring what your goals are.
Okay. So, there's no one true
evaluation. Choose what uh you're trying
to measure.
Um and you know, we talked about a bunch
of different uh benchmarks, starting
with perplexity, exam base, uh chat,
agentic, uh reasoning safety. Um they
are
vary in terms of, you know, difficulty,
realism, how valid they are, and there's
often tradeoffs. It's hard to have
really real and difficult and
ecologically valid and no train test
contamination. So, often you have to
compromise on one of these factors, and
depending on your goals, you will have
to choose which one you're willing to
compromise on.
Okay. So, that is uh the end of this
lecture. So, next week, we're going to
start talking about training uh data.
Okay. See you next time.